it's a story we see often during times
of war women forced to work long hours
and grueling manual jobs with husbands
fathers or brothers killed by fighting
many of these Yemeni women of different
ages are now the main source of income
for their families
bushra lives in the southwestern city of
ties with no one to look after two
children she takes them with her to work
the circumstances made us get a job it
has plenty of difficulties but what can
I do
I'll work even if they tell me to dig a
hole in a mountain for my children I'll
do anything
bushra is one of a number of women in
her village defying traditional norms
here labor is usually done by men but
it's not been easy the women have faced
a backlash from their communities
despite it being their only source for a
meager $50 a month the work is hard and
tiring I used to work as a painter and
I'd come home filthy we had objections
to us working but would tell them we
have to feed our children we received
help from organizations but not anymore
I'm in a difficult situation community
leader Abdul Hafez of Canaan II says
locals complained about women doing
manual labor and mixing with men but
things are changing yes the cumin and
some traditional parts of Yemen society
frowns upon working women but we're
seeing a change society is starting to
accept the idea that those especially
widowed divorced or displaced women are
alone
a United Nations funded program called
cash for work is teaching men and women
basic skills to help them get jobs
they've worked in different kinds of
jobs like flooring painting school
restorations agriculture and tar making
roads even though the community refuses
women to work they have no choice this
is what forced many of them to take part
in this project years of war in Yemen
have devastated its population but one
way to help women get through it has
been achieved by making small changes at
the community level so that a Haider al
Jazeera